il y a quatre ans, quand je suis arrivé à Orange
Park High, je savais que je
serais ici aujourd'hui en tant que major de la promotion.
Je vous ai jeté un coup d'œil dans ma
classe senior et j'ai pensé que j'allais
gagner.
est le plan de
notre avenir nous avions 13 ans une orientation pour
un concours de beauté Miss India Golden State
salut je suis rishabh Miss India national
Kareem Lilly qu'est-ce que tu es que ta
petite amie
mm-hmm avait un plan cette bosse sur la
route ne va pas  pour changer que tu as raison
je suis gagnante j'entre dans le concours
ce que Miss India Golden State tu oublies
que je fais le concours je ne peux pas être
vaincu par eux par qui Kareem et
quel est son visage dont tu as besoin pour trouver ta
beauté intérieure  reine je peux faire ça oh tu as
besoin de couler comme de l'eau
ce n'est pas comme si je t'avais montré ce que
tu portes comme des bretelles comme ça qui est-
ce que Sonia Nielson ah elle est encore
plus magnifique dans la vraie vie croyez-moi c'est
nous deux course  tu es peut être un
peu plus intelligent qu'elle  est oh ouais elle est
un peu plus difficile cependant et maintenant le
moment que nous attendons tous
salut salut oh merci
mon dieu